[Musique]
steve st cyr bonjour bonjour mes gars
oui alors vous êtes candidat à
sainte-luce pour les prochaines
élections municipales et communautaires
vous avez été désigné donc comme
candidat par le parti pays acp et puis
votre groupe politique dans la commune
de sainte luce est ce que vous voulez
bien vous présenter d'abord donc aux
auditrices aux auditeurs et aux
internautes steve facilement tout
d'abord bonjour à tous les auditeurs de
radio martinique qui est plus
particulièrement lycéens et lycéennes
donc steve st cyr
je suis lucéens de souche je suis né à
sainte luce de parents lucien de
plusieurs générations à ça plus donc je
participe beaucoup à la vie associative
de sainte-luce dandy aux associations je
suis actif au niveau de sainte luce je
me permets de de pouvoir accéder à
certaines choses et économiquement
j'investis à sainte luce physiquement je
m'investis à sainte luce je suis un
enfant de la commune et je veux voir ma
commune évolué et vous avait 46 ans
c'est bien ça tout à fait j'ai pas
trompés et donc vous avez été désigné
par pays acp et leurs
ses principaux dirigeants en
l'occurrence donc jean philippe miller
est marcellin nadeau et toute l'équipe
pour dont quatre candidats et succéder
ainsi à jean philippe miller qui s'est
présenté lui plusieurs fois dont la
dernière fois en 2014 aux municipales à
sainte luce donc oui je j'ai le soutien
de pays à l'investiture de pays acp dont
je suis membre et jean-philippe ni l'onu
ni notre groupe politique à sainte-luce
m'ont fait confiance pour pouvoir
reprendre cette tête de liste et mener
les prochaines municipales alors le nom
le nom du groupe
enfin l'instant nous n'avons pas choisi
de nom de l'est de metz ça se fera
bientôt les choses se font alors steve
st cyr qu'est ce qui vous a poussé vous
justement jeune homme de 46 ans à
vouloir briguer ce mandat de maire alors
je suis un je suis un militant depuis de
nombreuses années je m'intéresse à la
politique depuis plus d'une quinzaine
d'années et ayant participé à plusieurs
élections je ne me sent une âme de
dirigeants et voulant passer
l'amendement commune qui m'a poussé à me
présenter à ces élections
je suis né à sète les iem beaucoup ma
commune j'ai envie de voir ma commune
évolué j'ai envie de voir ma commune
changé et il ya des projets qui me
tiennent à coeur à cette liste que j'ai
envie de mener à sa tombe très bien si
vous êtes élu dans quelques semaines à
la tête de l'édilité lucéenne quel sera
le dossier que vous allez prendre en
urgence
vous allez vouloir traiter en urgence
moi meilleur demain j'aimerais pouvoir
mener
certains projets à bien nous avons un
projet qui nous tient à coeur d'un monde
dans notre groupe c'est le front de mer
de sainte luce qui vont nous doit être
que réaménage valoriser on va y venir
steve st cyr mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que est ce que vous trouvez que la
municipalité fonctionne bien
qu'allah d'une bonne santé financière
est ce que vous aurez tous les moyens de
pouvoir faire votre politique alors
quelques francs on sait pas exactement
comment sont les caisses mais enfin
voilà parce que vous n'êtes pas
conseiller municipal me semble-t-il
non je ne suis pas possible mais vous
avez des relais vous avez des jets d eau
lait nous avons plusieurs élus au
conseil municipal
donc les informations je les ai non
alors donc est ce que c'est une
sympathique et qui dans un état au sein
ça que je fais partie des communes où la
municipalité a un budget sain et qui ne
se retrouve pas en difficulté
donc nous avons nous aurons les moyens
de pouvoir faire les choses
convenablement et de mener nos affaires
comme nous entendons très bien
alors donc vous parliez du littoral qui
est très animée dès le jeudi 1 dé la mer
dès le mercredi même voilà le alors le
littoral du centre bourg 1 mais parce
que le littoral us et plus et a été très
long mais donc vous en parliez vous vous
en faites une priorité alors pour nous
c'est une des priorités parce que nous
voulons aussi développer la commune sur
un plan économique
donc il faut c'est avec les lycéens si
au coeur des lucien que nous voulons
nous voulons mener les choses
nous avons des commerçants au centre
cobo qui ont investi qui ont des
activités commerciales qui fonctionne et
qu'on aimerait voir se développer qu'on
aimerait voir dans de meilleures
conditions
parce qu'à l'heure actuelle dans le
centre bourg il faudrait pouvoir mettre
en place un réaménagement avec les
commerçants au caire des commerçants
pour pouvoir
mais dire demain matin à toute la
martinique de pouvoir venir à cette
liste
pour terminer en quelques mots messin
plus ce n'est pas que la mère s'est
tenue ce n'est pas que la mer nous avons
aussi des projets de développement au
niveau de l'agriculture
malheureusement l'agriculture n'a pas
été au centre que de la dernière
municipalité et pour nous il nous avons
à coeur de mettre en valeur les terres
de sainte luce qui ne sont pas que leur
déconner et de valoriser aussi la pêche
à sainte luce voilà voilà même si
effectivement la mer la baignade et les
plages de sainte luce sont très belles
et très agréable à pratiquer voilà merci
steve st cyr d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
mais à s'y masser kadri
[Musique]